a new study by longstarter has found
that the top five dirtiest cities in
America run by Democratic Mayors I would
have never guessed it obviously it's a
surprise what it's not like we brought
this up when we talked to uh uh Roland
Martin which was a fantastic friendly
conversation sweet shout out to him for
being here I respect the fact that he
showed up Houston ranked first
for the dirtiest City anybody here from
Houston by the way anybody oh we got a
couple people from Houston we love you
Houston my wife's from Houston we got
nothing against Houston if you got any
complaints write to this guy what's his
name that's you it's Jessica Jessica
chasma uh is writing this article
Houston is the dirtiest City followed by
Newark San Bernardino Detroit and Jersey
City these cities were measured across
four categories pollution living
conditions infrastructure and consumer
satisfaction Houston was rated as the
dirtiest City in rent ranked third on
pollution fourth on poor living
conditions and 12th on infrastructure
and 34th on consumer satisfaction
Virginia Beach the cleanest city in the
country is ran by a Republican mayor
Robert Dyer the City ranked 149th on
pollution and 132nd on consumer
satisfaction Tom why why would this be a
factor for cleanest and dirtiest cities
ran by Republican or Democrat what do
they have to do with it I think when you
go to a world of entitlement and you're
not allowing look when business invests
what do they do they build a building
they build areas around the building
you're investing in it and when you take
a look at all these things this is the
outcome of entitlement Houston I think
and Rob you could find this is like
number one in worse traffic in America
poor infrastructure investment they
managed to pass Los Angeles which has
had like the World Cup of bad traffic
four or five freeway oh my gosh yeah
it's it's incredible and what this is if
you fail to invest in the infrastructure
and you're just running on tax the rich
and entitlement you're not really
improving the condition of the city and
this is what you get this is the outcome
and you go down all these lists that
people say this this this this and this
and they say wow you know take a look at
this and I don't think it's a
coincidence that it's you know Democrat
you know Administration is doing this I
think dirty has to do with politics you
think dirty has to do with Democrat and
Republican like like for a crime I
understand when we're talking crime 27
out of 30 because we talk about the fact
that you're funding into so so let me
ask you a different question what can a
mayor do to make their City cleaner what
can a mayor do what policies can a mayor
come up with to make their cities
cleaner I you know when you enable
entrepreneurship and you enable job
creation people have jobs and people and
you're going to reduce homelessness so
anybody that's been the San Francisco
sees with the outcome of chronic
homelessness looks like in LA you get
people off the streets and you have the
ability to reinvest in schools and you
have the opportunity to do this you know
it's very simple if you promote economic
growth and tax it reasonably you've got
money to work with to improve your city
it's that simple and not being political
how then how is it I mean it's
technically political because if the top
five damn dirtiest cities are Democrat
and in the top five were with Roland
Martin you said that for crime like
Chicago it it is well they're all
Democratic but to me the way I go is if
it's crime I say okay Chicago got it
what do you do well you don't have guns
you don't have you know license to carry
let's just say or certain way they
handle structure for second amendment in
Chicago versus another city that's maybe
in Idaho or how they handle it here or
how to handle it in Texas then you can
kind of say fine that makes sense and
then hey let's defund the police or
let's what's the word the other word for
defunding the police it's a asset uh
reallocation which is another definition
for defunding the police then you can
directly say there's a reason why this
City's crime is so high but dirty dirty
is what how do you What policies cause a
city to be cleaner
What policies yes please
show use jails inmates to help come and
clean the cities okay
so leverage them to come in and help
clean the cities I that's the part but I
wonder if it's on the people if it's on
the mayor I mean obviously the leader of
the city has to figure out a way to make
make it cleaner well what policies do
you come up with like is it you know
like the uh uh how many guys have a city
where if you get caught loitering
there's a ticket to it there's uh
literally not like you your your uh yeah
when you're littering there's a ticket
to it do you guys is that 100 but so
you're saying is Pat just like the the
meter maids why not have people like on
the street like I know Los Angeles has
safety ambassadors they don't have guns
or anything they just kind of like if
there is like a somebody yelling or
there's an argument they come to kind of
I was hoping to solve all the problems
on today's podcast we're failing right
now guys just so you know well uh I have
a I have an idea uh well why don't we
get Mayor Pete who was the the mayor of
South Bend Indiana now the department of
uh Transportation secretary okay yeah I
think there's a new top
uh dirtiest city in America right now
yes Palestine Ohio so I know they're
dealing with a lot with that
um I I I this I don't think there's any
simple fix here's what I do know
um like what do you think the biggest
city the biggest city in the country
that voted Republican in the last
election Trump
what do you think the biggest city was
anyone
200 people here nobody's got a big city
that you think voted
so there's zero big cities that have
voted Republican zero the top 50. so you
know think about even the red Estates
Alabama okay what's its capital of
Birmingham Democrat Texas Dallas
Democrat uh go down the list uh we we
all know the Republican states we know
the red States okay but the the bigger
the city the more people the more
liberal they tend to be the more open
they are to new ideas now some of it is
a little ridiculously far-fetched but
the more conservative the city is the
more that they're kind of like let's
just stay how things are so I think the
bigger the city gets the more likely it
is to have a Democratic mayor so so you
just well that's a different
conversation though so let's finalize
this topic and let's go to the next one
here's what I would say I think it is a
cultural thing the more I by the way I
wasn't I don't have like the solution or
the answer to it did you guys see what
happened at World Cup when Japan came
and played what they did afterwards did
anybody see the clips right afterwards
what happened did you see this or no
they cleaned all this bleachers
fans yeah yeah they cleaned everything
after themselves and you're like wow
yeah so then other countries who were
playing they were kind of like let's do
the same thing as well and it became
like a cultural thing for us to clean up
there they go and and you're like wow
this is not what we do in Germany or
this is not what we do in U.S or this is
not what we do in such and such and
other people started picking it up I
don't know I think if somebody from the
top is speaking about it you definitely
can do something about it you know the
old San Francisco story have you guys
been to San Francisco lately or not who
is part who's from San Francisco
actually anybody from San Francisco have
they started cleaning up San Francisco
is it can you say it louder to the
people in the back that can't hear you
and he's from San Francisco right so
just 10 years ago babe when was it you
and I went to San Fran we'd go there
regularly was that eight years ago 10
years ago five years ago
we went when we went to Napa you're
right yes and
AIG I remember that and and the place
well by the way great meeting it was
there so the place was cleaned and he'll
look forward to going to San Francisco
versus today you go to it we were there
I'm like what the hell is going on look
at this yeah this this does not look
like San Francisco looks like a complete
different city the responsibility is on
the mayor I guess one of the things
could be said is what is the standard
that you take with homelessness what is
the standards that you take with fines
what is the standard with cultural they
were hey what if we had a one day
cleaning day let's all get out there and
clean the city what if we did something
culturally that we can make this place a
better place what if we did something
like that you don't remember the day
that in California to deal with gas they
did the one day you couldn't drive uh
who remembers that one day who remembers
uh anybody remembers 405 was closed or
the one-on-one what was it called
how long ago was that like
2013 when they did that and it was one
day everybody took a break and it was
one way of doing this imagine you're the
mayor of a city you're like listen guys
here's what we're doing uh we have
gotten the top 20 CEOs of the top 20
companies in our city and here's what we
got in all the CEOs to agree to do one
day paid leave
to go out there and all of us volunteer
to clean our city wouldn't that be a
sick idea if somebody who would vote for
that bother how many guys would be like
yeah I'm okay we're going out there
doing supporting it I think it's
something like that that they got to do
to clean their cities so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]